The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good.
So let us start.
So let me first
quickly remind you
what we did in the last lecture.
So we first talked
about the-- so we
talked general observables
and gauge series.
So we're interested in
correlation functions
of gauge invariant operators.
In particular, we will be
focused on local operators.
So we say, for example-- so
the local operator can also
be separated into, say,
the single trace operator.
Yeah, the single trace operator.
So n just labels
different operators.
Or say that the double
trace operator-- sometimes,
in order to avoid confusion,
we put some thoughts
that means these
two operators should
be considered grouped together.
And then you evaluate it
at some spacetime point.
Say this would be a
double trace operator.
Or maybe the higher ones.
OK?
And also, we found that a
typical correlation function--
say if I look at
endpoint function,
endpoint connect
equaling function
of single trace
operators, then the scale,
with n as [INAUDIBLE],
again, you
sum over all the h, which is
the topology of your diagrams.
And then to the power
n to the minus n-- n
is the number of the endpoint
functions-- the minus 2h.
Than say some function.
Fn, which can depend
on the coupling
constants and also will depend
on x1, x2, xn, et cetera.
OK?
So this will start us
leading order with N 2
minus n, which come
from the planar diagram.
And then the next order,
just N to the minus n.
So this will be
the torus diagram.
The diagram you can put on
the torus Or genus 2 diagrams.
OK?
Et cetera.
So we also discussed
that this behavior
has important
physical implications.
We talked about
two implications.
You say that kind of
independence means that,
in the larger limit-- say in
the N go to infinity limit-- we
can essentially treat the
action of the single particle--
a single trace operator on
the vacuum-- as generating
a single particle state.
We often call this
as glueballs state.
Glueballs, OK?
So this single
particle state, they
don't have to appear
really as, say,
a symptotic state in your
scattering, et cetera.
It just say the
behavior of such state
behaves like single particles.
And then, if you act on
the double trace operator,
on the 0, then that gives
you the two particle state,
and et cetera.
And the triple trace operator
will give you the three
particle state, et cetera.
OK?
So this is one aspect.
And the second aspect
is that if-- say
if there is some single
trace operator whose
expectation value is non-zero,
then the fluctuations
are suppressed.
OK?
So for example, if you look
at the ratio of the variance,
so O squared, the
connected part of the O
squared, is essentially
the variance of this guy.
And divided by
expectation value itself,
the scale is 1 over N
because of that behavior,
and this goes to 0.
OK?
In the margin, as
N goes to infinity.
So that means the
fluctuations are suppressed.
So any questions regarding this?
Good?
OK.
So now let's talk
about the third aspect
of it, the third implication.
So now, suppose we interpret
this endpoint function, so
this connected
endpoint function,
say we check it symbolically
as, say, some kind of blob.
Then you have [INAUDIBLE] x.
Say 1, 2, 3-- n minus 1, n.
OK?
So each line means an
external operator insertions.
So if we interpret this as some
kind of scattering amplitude,
so as generates some kind of
scattering amplitude over the n
glueballs, then you can show,
because of this behavior,
you can show, because
of this N scaling.
And then, again,
to leading order,
in the N goes to infinity limit,
the scatterings are classical.
Classical means-- you said
it only involves tree level
scatterings.
OK?
So now I'm going to show this.
This is the conclusion.
So now I'm going to
justify this statement.
So before I start
justifying this statement,
do you have any questions?
Good.
So let me just
make a few remarks.
So first-- so let's look
at the simplest case, which
is the three point function.
So the three point function
can be considered just
as effective vertex.
It can be considered
as an effective vertex
of three particles
intact with each other.
Say one glueball is split
into two glueballs, et cetera.
OK?
So this, from that definition,
scales as 1 over n.
OK?
This scales as 1 over n.
So if we treat it as
a basic vertex-- so
suppose we treat it.
Suppose we treat it as a
basic vertex with coupling g.
So g is 1 over N. OK.
The from simple, then
to easy to see, then
tree-level amplitudes for
n-particle scattering,
n-particle scatterings
are precisely
scaled as g to the
n minus 2, which
is n to the power
minus 2 minus N.
And then this is precisely--
we see for the leading scaling
here.
OK?
So is this fact obvious to you,
that the tree-level scattering
for n-particles with basic
vertex given by g will scale
like this?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Why is it proportional to g?
Because each-- they start
in a double line notation.
Each line contributes
to like a g square.
So how that g comes from--
PROFESSOR: Now, which g
you are talking about?
Oh, no, no, no.
Maybe let me call it--
it's a different g.
It's a different-- yeah,
let me call it kappa.
Or let me call it g tilde.
Yeah, it's not the same.
It's not the same g as before.
This is just something
I-- [INAUDIBLE] there.
I just call it some
kind effective coupling.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Just imagine you have a
process whose basic interaction
vertex is g tilde, and g
tilde is order 1 over N.
And then the tree-level
scattering for n particle
will depend on this coupling
to be g tilde to the n minus 2.
OK?
So this clear to you?
Yeah.
You can just draw
a tree diagram.
You can see the immediate tree.
OK?
So this is consistent.
So this behavior is consistent
to interpret that as a tree.
But you don't actually
have to assume
the basic three-point vertex.
So you can also say-- you can
also include-- higher order
vertices.
But your vertices
which include should be
consistent with this scaling.
OK?
Suppose if you're want to
inclue four-particle vertices.
And then this should
scale as g tilde squared,
which is N to the
minus 2, because
the four-point connective
function should
scale as minus 2.
And similarly, if you
have a five-point vertex,
then it should scale
as g tilde to the cube,
which is N to the minus 3.
The five-point function
should scale as N minus 3.
OK?
So you can also add such
higher order vertices
as far as you are consistent
with this large N scaling.
So then you can easily
convince yourself
that even including such
higher order vertices does not
change this conclusion, that the
N-point tree-level amplitude,
again for n-particles,
will scale like this.
OK?
Will not change that conclusion.
So this is second statement.
And these two statements, just
to give you a heuristic way
to see that this kind of scaling
can be generated-- indeed,
generated by
tree-level scatterings.
So now I'm going to
prove that in the large N
limit to leading order, in N,
in any such kind of correlation
functions, there are
no more than one--
there's no more--
there are only, maybe.
Let me just say it easier.
There are only one particle
intermediate states.
OK?
So I'm going to show this.
So let's consider, say, a three
part-- so by one particle,
I always mean one
particle in this sense.
OK?
So one particle in this sense.
So I read through it a
little bit heuristically.
It's not very precise,
but I think it's rigorous,
but it's not-- but they will not
[? right ?] the precise-- yeah,
will not [? right ?]
rigorous formulas.
So let's consider,
just as an example,
consider the
three-point scattering,
three-point functions.
Say I have three operators.
And look at this connected
[INAUDIBLE] function.
OK?
So now, in those places,
we can, in principle,
insert the complete
set of states.
OK?
And those can be considered
as intermediate states--
contribute to this process.
So if I consider a
scattering process,
and then I can insert a
complete set of states here,
then those states which gives
a nontrivial contribution
can be considered
as a contribution
from some intermediate states.
OK?
So for example, let me introduce
a single particle state
here-- say this O1, O2, O3.
Suppose I insert a complete
set of-- so I insert a 1 here.
This 1, we include the sum of
all possible single particle
states and also include possible
two-particle states, et cetera.
OK?
And look at the [INAUDIBLE]
equaling function.
OK?
Yeah, just heuristically,
when I insert
the complete set
of states, I can
insert [INAUDIBLE] like that.
So now let's look
at the scaling.
So this scale, according to
our general behavior actually
scales as 1 over N. OK?
So this guy is
indeed scale as 1.
So two-point function still
says 1, N to the power of 0.
And then this guy scales
as N to the power minus 1.
So this term is OK.
So insertion of the single
particle state is OK.
But now, this will give you
a higher order contribution,
because this scales
as N equal to minus 1.
And this scales as
N equal to minus 2.
So all together,
this contributes to N
to the minus 3.
OK?
So the contribution of
the two particle states,
they will be suppressed
compared to the contribution
of the single particle states.
And similarly, with higher--
even higher-- even more
particle states.
OK?
So if I draw a diagram, this
process is like the following.
It said I can start with 1.
And then this 1 can,
say, turn into i
through a two-point function.
And then this i can
go to 2 and a 3.
OK?
So this is a tree-level process.
And this is like the following.
So this is a two-particle state.
So this, if I draw a
diagram, would be like
if I started with 1.
And then this 1
can split into ij.
And then this ij
combines into 2, 3.
OK?
So this is like a
one-loop process.
OK?
And this, we see,
it's N to the minus 3.
And this is indeed
just N to the minus 1.
So this is suppressed
compared to that.
So this is a direct way
to say that, in this kind
of-- to leading order, indeed,
can only tree-level processes.
You can never have
these kind of loops.
Because whenever you have a
loop, then of course one of you
must have a multi-particle.
You must have multi-particle
intermediate states.
And then they're
[INAUDIBLE] Is it clear?
So this tells you that
all loops are suppressed.
And so abc together--
so this abc together,
then justify the statement
that to leading order.
this scattering amplitude
involving only tree-level.
When you have only a
tree-level scattering,
then this is like
a classical story.
Only size you land in quantum
field theory in the loops
can be considered as
quantum fluctuations.
And if you only have
trees, it's essentially
just a classical process.
So when you solve the
classical equation motion,
and then what do you get?
It's the tree-level processes.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What is the number
of operators [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Hm?
AUDIENCE: What is the number
of operators in the sum?
PROFESSOR: Right.
That's a very good question.
And essentially, by definition,
such operator only scales.
Essentially, by
definition, such kind
of so-called single trace
operators and the scale set--
yeah, there's no--
yeah, just the way
you can make such
single trace operator
is not proportional
to N. Questions?
AUDIENCE: What is-- each of
these terms individually small,
but when you take
summation over them--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, that's the
question was just asked.
So those operators,
if you count them,
the number of single trace
operators you can construct
is independent of N. And so so
when you suppress them by N.
There is nothing you
can compensate them.
In principle, yeah, there's
nothing can compensate them.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So how many
operators that are Oi, Oj
can you construct?
What is the magnitude?
PROFESSOR: Oh, it's an
infinite number of them.
It's an infinite number of them.
But the key is the
infinite [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: It's a
factor of infinite.
We can just--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's infinite.
It's infinite.
But compared to the large N
limit, it's still order 1.
[LAUGHS]
It's infinite.
It's infinite, but it's
order N to the power 0.
AUDIENCE: Oh, my gosh.
AUDIENCE: All right.
PROFESSOR: It's N
to the power of 0.
And so they will be suppressed,
by physical process.
So for example,
say this operator--
say I have some dimension.
Say this operator-- suppose this
Particle 1 have some energy.
And a particle has some energy.
And then the process of
this generated this, too.
And when their energy
becomes very large,
then it's suppressed.
And you have this kind
of physical suppression.
Of course, if you
include all energies,
there are an infinite
number of them.
But in fact, if you
can-- if you consider,
yeah, energy [INAUDIBLE]
this kind of thing.
Then essentially, there's a
finite number of contributes.
AUDIENCE: Finite.
OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
But the key is that this is
order N to the power of 0.
AUDIENCE: Maybe one more thing--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What if it includes
the loop, closed by itself?
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Like a closed
fermion loop [INAUDIBLE]
I mean, it doesn't need to
involve [INAUDIBLE] state.
It can just [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
Loop always involves
particle states.
So any loop, when you cross
it, there's always two states.
AUDIENCE: Don't they need
to cross it at the end?
I mean, like a [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry, I
don't quite understand.
Any loop, by definition,
when you cross it,
there's always two points.
Then that means this is
more than one particle.
AUDIENCE: Just something
like this, don't cross any--
PROFESSOR: No, no, no, no, no.
You cross here.
You still have two particles.
AUDIENCE: Right.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
you cut at any time.
There's still two particles.
OK.
Let's summarize.
So now let's combine 1, 2, 3.
So we can combine 1, 2, 3.
So this tells us--
so this 1, 2, 3
tells us at leading order
in large N expansion,
we have a series--
a classical series.
We essentially just have a
classical series of glueballs.
You just have a
bunch of particles,
and they interact classically.
There's no quantum fluctuations.
And we see interactions
among glueballs, among them,
given by some effective company
which I call g tilde, which
scales as 1 over N. OK?
Scales as 1 over N.
So let me just elaborate this
statement a little bit more.
So this can be
considered as, say,
when we take a gauge theory--
say, for [INAUDIBLE] theory.
Say QCD.
You take N goes
to infinity limit.
And you take h bar finite.
So by definition, when we
talk about this theory,
h bar is always finite.
But in the N equals
infinity limit,
this is equivalent
to a glueball theory
where h bar tilde goes to 0.
OK.
So you get the classical
theory and with effective h
bar tilde, which is controlled,
essentially, by 1 over N
goes to 0.
OK?
So here, you can do
perturbative expansion 1 over N.
So this is just a leading order.
Here, you can do perturbative
expansion in 1 over N.
So in this side,
it's like some kind
of semi-classical
expansion in this h
tilde, which, of course, should
be scaled as 1 over N. OK?
So on this side, when
h bar tilde goes to 0,
you have a classical theory.
But then you can do
expansion h tilde.
So this is one that
we normally call
a semi-classical expansion.
OK?
So the large N expansion
has been translated
into some semi-classical
expansion when you translate
into this glueball [INAUDIBLE].
And we're now--
so is this clear?
Yeah, this is a little
bit small corner.
Is it readable?
Yeah.
This is a very
important statement.
Maybe I should rewrite it.
Yeah, let me just rewrite it.
So perturbative expansion--
perturbation in N, in 1 over N.
So this is equal to
semi-classical expansion
in h bar tilde, which
scales 1 over N. OK.
And we will now show that these
guys, this glueball theory,
and this semi-classical
expansion,
is actually a string theory.
OK?
No, we will not show that.
I say I will motivate that.
I say that's a string theory.
So before I go that, do
you have any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just to
clarify, doesn't
the sort of second
statement-- the fact
that the perturbation
1 over N corresponds
with semi-classical
expansion in h bar tilde,
isn't that just a generalization
of the thing you just wrote?
It's the same statement.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
the same statement.
No, no, no.
This true statement, they are--
AUDIENCE: Basically the same.
PROFESSOR: They
are not equivalent.
This is talking about
this particular limit.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: This is talking
about this particular limit.
And then this tells
you what happens
when we'll relax this limit by
including [INAUDIBLE] fact by 1
over N expansion.
And to make this
identification-- so this
by itself does not imply that.
AUDIENCE: The other
way does, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Of course, the other way does.
So this is a stronger statement.
AUDIENCE: Right.
OK.
PROFESSOR: Under
this statement, it's
supported by just looking at
the leading model behavior.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: But if you want
to look at this behavior,
and then you look
at-- then you need
to look at the sub-reading
terms of 1 over N.
Say, for example, here.
Then you see the
fluctuation is controlled
by 1 over N. It's like your
by h bar.
And similarity,
here, then when you
include 1 over N
[INAUDIBLE], then you
will see a single particle.
And the two particle,
multi-particle particle,
they can mix together
due to fluctuations.
And again, that
amplitude controlled by 1
over N, et cetera.
Yeah, just say this
statement is stronger.
You need to look at sub-reading
corrections carefully,
and you'll see that fits
into an h bar pattern.
AUDIENCE: Great.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So instead
of this [INAUDIBLE],
we consider regular
creation-- [INAUDIBLE]
Do we still come
to the conclusion
that all the loop
diagrams are trace?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's a good point.
So in essence, you
can imagine this Oi,
each Oi defines-- this point,
1, is precisely a statement.
So you can imagine
each Oi defines
a creation-- defines
an independent creation
under [INAUDIBLE] operator.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
theory [INAUDIBLE]
expression of both diagrams.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
No, in the original
theory, we are not.
Only in the large N limit.
AUDIENCE: So in the original
theory, in the large N limit,
we do have suppression?
PROFESSOR: No.
You don't have a
suppression of loop diagram
in terms of the standard loops.
You only have the
suppression of the loop
diagram in terms of
those loops-- in terms
of loops of glueballs.
AUDIENCE: But here
we don't specify--
don't put any restrictions
on what are the operators O.
So why can't we say
just Oi is just psi i?
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
O is [INAUDIBLE] operator,
O is composite operator.
O is some composite operator.
So for example, in the
[INAUDIBLE] series,
so one example is O
can be TrF squared.
So if you look at the
two-point function of O,
then that's corresponding
to two gluon propagators.
And you have loops here.
But this is not the loop
in terms of the glueballs
here when we talk about loops--
yeah, so let me emphasize.
All loops of glueballs.
Because here-- so the
key of this statement
is that in a large
N limit-- and if you
can see-- if our thing is
gauge invariant operators,
then that's a [INAUDIBLE]
that you should consider.
And if you're not worried
about the original stuff.
And those that have loops,
et cetera, [INAUDIBLE] the h
bar, et cetera.
But in terms of those
glueballs, then you
have a classical theory.
There's no loops.
You only have
tree-level scattering
in the large N limit.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So are we
getting a general gauge
of varying operators
or explicitly
single trace operators?
PROFESSOR: No, no.
I have talked about everything.
AUDIENCE: So I mean
like the single--
a single O operator can
be several traces inside?
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
Single O is a single trace.
It's a single trace
that's defined there.
AUDIENCE: What about non-trace
gauge invariance operators?
PROFESSOR: We don't
consider them.
Oh, you mean non-trace
gauge invariant operator?
No, every gauging variance
operator always involves trace.
AUDIENCE: Always?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, sure.
You will be a
famous mathematician
if you can construct
something invariant which
does not involve a trace.
Yeah, construct something
about the matrix.
Construct something
using matrices
which does not involve traces.
Yeah.
Even if you do determinant,
and determinant
can still be written as traces.
Yeah.
Yeah, just everything
can be written as traces.
AUDIENCE: So
determinant would just
have-- if you have a
determinant operator, that
can just be written as
a product of many Os.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
That's right.
Good.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just to clarify,
we've been talking about
the-- [INAUDIBLE] [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Here, we are
talking about only--
every field is
matrix valued fields.
Just every field is
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I don't
know, I just-- I
thought there was more
invariance that you
can construct [INAUDIBLE].
Like I was asking
you the other day,
basically it's all
of the-- each one
of the coefficients of
the characters [INAUDIBLE]
polynomial of a matrix.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, they
can be written as traces.
Yeah, they can be
written as traces.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I
didn't know that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Usually we
don't discuss quarks here.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, here we have--
not as quarks.
And we're going to mention
quarks very briefly at the end.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
Good.
OK.
So now let's talk a little
about string theory.
Maybe I will leave it there.
Let me see where
they leave that.
Yeah, let me leave that.
OK.
So first we'll talk a little
bit about the strings.
So first, let me
remind you, QFT,
normally when we
say a QFT, we say
QFT is a series of particles.
OK?
So the standard
approach to the QFT--
say you write down a
field theory Lagrangian,
and then you quantize
the [INAUDIBLE].
So this is normally called
the second quantized.
So the standard
approach is called
the second quantized approach.
So you can quantize
the approach.
OK?
But there also exists a
first quantized approach.
There also exists a
Say you directly quantize-- you
just quantize a quantum motion,
say, over a particle
or particles.
Say this is considered
one particle-- say
a particle in spacetime.
OK?
So for example, if you can
see the particle propagate
in spacetime along some
trajectory-- so let's
parametrized this trajectory
using a parameter by tau, which
labeled a point
along the trajectory,
and then, so this will
give you a mapping.
Say the trajectory will map
out the trajectory-- yeah,
so this will map out the
trajectory in spacetime,
which can be written as
a spacetime coordinate
as a function of tau.
OK?
So this parametrized the
[INAUDIBLE] of the particle.
And to quantize the
particle, the simplest way
is to imagine just sum
over all possible paths
over the particle.
So essentially, we're
doing a path integral.
Essentially we're
So you just integrate over all
possible paths of a particle,
and then this is essentially
a quantum motion.
Just quantum mechanically,
it can fluctuate, anyway.
And then this particle-- then
this action, for the particle,
essentially it's just the lens.
So suppose the
particle has mass m,
it's just in the lens
of the particle, dl,
along the trajectory.
OK?
And if you include
interactions, then you
have to include the
trajectories into which
the particle can split.
Say a line can split in
two lines, et cetera.
So this gives you
interactions, et cetera.
OK?
And this we need to add by
hand, because the particle
in principle can-- you can draw
infinite ways of particle split
into more particles, et cetera.
So depend on your
specific theories,
you need to specify,
say, the interactions.
So this, you need add by hand.
OK.
So in principle, you can forget
about the standard formulation
of quantum field theory just to
work with this particle theory.
So the string theory
is a generalization
of this first
quantized approach.
So string theory, as is
currently formulated,
is formulated in this
first quantized approach.
So you just quantize motions
of a string in spacetime.
OK?
So for example,
so particle case,
you have a [INAUDIBLE]
particle string case,
you have a closed loop.
So imagine we have
a closed string.
OK?
You have a closed string.
A string is a
one-dimensional object,
so let's consider
a closed string.
Then the string can
be parametrized.
So the string itself
can be parametrized
say by a parameter,
sigma, along the string.
But then, then this string
can move in the spacetime.
Then we'll trace
out some trajectory.
Trace out some trajectory.
So this gives rise
to worldsheet.
So in the particle case,
you have a [INAUDIBLE].
So in the string case,
you have a worldsheet,
which we normally call sigma.
And then the sigma
can be, again, written
in terms of the spacetime
coordinates as a function
of this tau and the sigma.
Now you have two coordinates
to parametrize this worldsheet.
So this is essentially
a two-dimensional--
so essentially, you have
a two-dimensional surface
in the spacetime,
embedded in spacetime.
And the string theory
just quantized--
you just can see the motion
of all such kind of surfaces.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So in the case
of a single particle,
we have a point.
Does this action actually--
what does it reproduce exactly?
Is it capable of reproducing all
of quantum field theory using
this [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, in principle.
But it's not convenient.
Yeah, for example, if you
have a scalar particle,
this can certainly easily
reproduce your free scalar
field theory.
And if you want to
reproduce phi-cubed theory,
then you need to add this
kind of a split in your--
when you do your path integral
including the trajectories,
you need to include these
kind of trajectories.
Yeah, in principle,
you can do it.
It's not very convenient.
AUDIENCE: I see.
OK.
Interesting.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do
you add interactions
by hand in that particle?
PROFESSOR: Oh, well you
just [? recreate. ?]
In the path integral, here,
you integrate all such kind
of paths, right?
And then you have prescription.
You say, what kind
of paths to include.
And for example, if I have
phi-cubed kind of interaction,
then you say we should
include this kind of path.
AUDIENCE: But in case it cannot
be parametrized as a top,
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
Then you have to-- then there
are tactical complications
in doing these extensions.
AUDIENCE: So one other question.
Is string theory
formulated in terms
of-- is it possible to
perform a second quantization?
PROFESSOR: Not right now.
So people have written down
classical string field theory.
And in principle,
you can quantize it.
But that's a very
complicated thing.
But I think nobody have
successfully quantized it.
Even to write down the
theory is very non-trivial.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So similarly, to do
quantization for string,
you just look at
the-- you just can
see that the path integral--
so in principle, to do
the quantize of the
string, you can again just
imagine your sum over
all possible worldsheet
configurations.
All possible this
kind of embedding
of this two-dimensional
surface in spacetime,
then that essentially gives rise
to all kinds of string motions.
OK?
So weighted by
some string action.
So the simplest way to
write down the string action
is a straightforward
generalization
of this particle case, if I
just integrate over its area.
So here, it's just the
lens of the string.
Here, it's the area.
But here, we also
need to include--
so here is the particle mass.
So a generation of
the particle mass
is the so-called string tension.
So t, which is normally
written as 2 alpha prime.
So you introduce a parameter.
You introduce a dimensional
parameter alpha prime
to parametrize this t.
And so this is string tension.
So this is the mass per unit.
String tension is just
mass per unit length.
OK?
And this is normally called
a Nambu-Goto action, so NG.
So this is Nambu-Goto action,
who first wrote it down.
OK?
So the A is essentially
just the area
of the surface in the spacetime.
OK? it's just straight
generalization
of that length of
the trajectory.
And yeah, depend
on the worries--
depend on what kind of
questions you are interested,
then you try to track those
kind of physical answers
from this-- say
this path integral.
OK?
Any questions so far?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do we allow paths to
contract the string to a point?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
I will show you.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is that
2 times variable?
PROFESSOR: No, single.
No, sigma parametrized
the string itself,
and the tau, it parametrized
the motion of the string
along the motion of the string.
AUDIENCE: But there is a
time variable in sigma?
Or it's just a--
PROFESSOR: No, no.
Tau is the time.
Tau is the internal
time for the string.
And then, there's a time
in here-- in the x0,
in the spacetime.
So this can be
considered as some kind
of proper time for the string--
internal time for the string.
Yeah, just like you parametrized
the trajectory of the particle,
you have some tau to parametrize
the trajectory of the particle.
This is the same thing.
AUDIENCE: That means
so any proper time--
isn't a variance-- itself is
four-dimensional spacetime.
Why there is only like one
parameter of tau which does not
have these four components?
PROFESSOR: No, I don't
understand what you-- no,
there's only a single time.
You have a particle, you
have only a single time.
Right?
Now do you agree here
there's only tau here?
Now here, I just have a line.
I've parametrized this line.
I call it tau.
AUDIENCE: OK, yeah.
PROFESSOR: Here, I have
a two dimensional-- here,
I have a string.
And then each point on the
string moves like a particle.
And then my parametrize by tau.
It's the same thing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: You go ahead.
AUDIENCE: What's the
metric on the worldsheet?
Does that make sense to ask?
Because it's like
minus plus or--
PROFESSOR: Of course,
it makes sense.
Of course, on the
worldsheet, it should
be a Lorentz in-- whatever is
the metric on worldsheet will
be induced from the spacetime.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So it would be a minus plus.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, for example.
Yeah.
It's [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, you can also-- we
can talk about-- yes?
AUDIENCE: So one other question.
So if that should be
interpreted as proper time,
if I have a string
which is moving
in some weird,
non-uniform way, how
does it make sense to talk about
the proper time of the string
when you could imagine the
different points on the string?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
Good point.
So often, you cannot
talk about that.
And this just gives you
a heuristic picture.
Because in principle,
string can do a highly
non-classical motion.
And then that's what's
encoded, say integrating over
all such kind of surfaces.
And some of them, you
cannot interpret classically
or semi-classically into
this kind of picture.
You visualize it.
So I will draw some
pictures later.
You will see.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: This might be a
question without a good answer,
but what is the-- why does
the action take that form?
What is that
accomplishing physically?
Or I guess maybe
an easier example
would be up there in the
first quantization approach.
How does that
reproduce [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You say why
that produce gravity?
Yeah.
How that reproduces
gravity, of course,
is a technical
question which you
have to calculate explicitly.
But the question, you said,
why do we choose that?
The reason we
choose that is it's
based on various principles.
So first, that thing,
whatever it is,
should not depend on
how you choose this tau.
Because you can parametrize
your trajectory anywhere
you want so that the l-- so
whatever this action should not
depend on the parametrization.
And also, this action
should be Lorentz invariant,
and the Lorentz boost
should be translating
[INAUDIBLE], et cetera.
And with those conditions,
then essentially uniquely
determined to be this form.
It's [INAUDIBLE]
unique [INAUDIBLE] Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I guess
if you were doing
a quantization of
the bosonic string,
like if you were deriving
the field equations,
would you use Nambu-Goto
or would you use Polyakov?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
That's right.
If you really quantize it, you
actually don't use Nambu-Goto.
Nambu-Goto, you use it for
the classical description.
Yeah.
I did not mention
the other forms.
It's just for our current
discussion, it's not essential.
Yeah.
Indeed, when you
quantize it, you actually
use a different
form of this action.
Any other questions?
Good.
So now, for example,
say how you-- so it
depends on what kind of
questions you are interested,
and you try to extract them,
say, from this kind of path
integral.
And of course, this is a
highly non-trivial questions.
And they require, say, some kind
of trial and error, et cetera.
So let me just tell you-- say if
I want to calculate the vacuum
process.
Say if I want to calculate
the vacuum energy-- OK?
So let me call this Z string.
So remember, when we talk
about large N gauge series,
and if you want to
calculate the vacuum energy,
then you calculate the-- you
sum over all possible vacuum
diagrams, et cetera.
OK?
You sum over all
possible vacuum diagrams.
But suppose we want to calculate
the vacuum energy in the string
theory, and then you
do the similar thing.
You just do the, what do you
want to do for the string?
You say you sum over--
all closed 2D surfaces.
OK?
So the "closed"
here is essential.
So this is based
on the intuition
that when we-- in the quantum
field theory, when you sum over
fermion diagrams, and the
fermion diagrams heuristically
can be considered as a particle
trajectories, et cetera.
And for the vacuum process, none
of-- there's no external lags.
So everything coming
out of the vacuum then
come back to the vacuum.
So that's why-- so if we
want to calculate the vacuum
energy in the string
theory, and again,
corresponding to the
virtual string motion.
And again, the
virtual string motion
should correspond into the sum
of all such kind of services
without any external lags.
So it should be closed surfaces.
OK?
It should be closed surfaces.
So it's the analog
of the particle case.
So exactly as in the
quantum field theory case,
it's easier to do this using
the Euclidian-- by going
to the Euclidian
signature, and say
go to the Euclidian signature.
It's going to
Euclidian signature.
So essentially, analytic--
so instead of considering
a surface in the
Lorentzian spacetime,
you consider-- your
analytics continue
your spacetime,
the full spacetime
to the Euclidian signature.
And then this just
becomes some surface
in some Euclidean space.
And then this is just a much
easier mathematical object
to deal with.
OK?
So that's what you get.
And if you have a string,
and then you have this.
OK?
OK.
So now, when you sum
over all surfaces,
now you have a choice.
First, you can sum
over the topology.
So we talked about before--
or two-dimensional surfaces,
topologies classified
by this genus.
And then, you can sum over
surfaces with a given--
so you can separate the
sum into sum over topology
and then some surfaces of
a given topology, given h.
OK?
So this h is the genus.
So essentially, we
are just summing
of all possible two-dimensional
closed surfaces.
OK?
Is this point clear?
This is absolutely key point.
And with this, minus SNG.
OK?
So now there's a very
important mathematical trick.
And this mathematical trick
can be justified vigorously,
but I will not just put it here.
I will just add it here.
It says now, just in physic,s
whenever you see a discrete sum
like this, what do you do?
Or in mathematics, whenever you
see a discrete sum like this,
what do we do?
Hm?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
You add weight.
So here, I will
add a weight here.
So here, I am summing
of O topology.
But now I will add
by hand a weight
to weigh the different topology.
So lambda is just
some parameter.
So lambda is just a parameter
I introduced by hand myself.
OK?
So this is just the weight
for a different topology.
So chi is the Euler number.
So lambda is just
some-- so chi is
the Euler number, 2 minus 2h.
And the lambda just
can be considered
as some kind of
chemical potential--
some kind of chemical
potential, say, for topologies.
OK?
Yeah.
Yeah, just like
in the system, say
you have a conservative
charge, then
when you add particles,
different particle number,
it's convenient to add
a chemical potential.
So lambda is like that.
So even though I
added by hand now--
even though I added it by hand
here, but in string theory,
actually this is--
arises completely natural
from the string theory.
There's a rigorous way one
can show how that arises,
but I will not do it here.
It's not important
for our purpose.
And I will also introduce
a notation-- say gs
is equal to exponential lambda.
OK?
So now, let's look
at the summation.
So here, you sum over--
so at h equal to 0, you
sum over all surface with
the topology of a sphere.
And the weight is given
by gs minus 2, which
is expansion minus 2 lambda.
OK?
Now because the chi-- when h
equal to 0, chi equal to 2.
So this is just minus 2 lambda.
And so this is one
over gs squared.
OK?
And then the torus
is h equal to 1.
So this is just the
gs to the power 0.
So order 1.
If you have genus 2, so
this would be gh equal to 2,
and it would be gs squared.
OK?
So here is a remarkable fact.
Here is a remarkable fact.
It said summing over topology
automatically includes
interaction of strings.
OK?
In fact, this fully specifies
string interactions.
OK?
So let me just elaborate
on this statement.
So we can see this statement
from these sums here.
OK?
So now let's look at
the physical meaning
of those diagrams.
So let's first look at
the sphere diagrams.
So suppose we draw a sphere.
OK?
So what I'm describing
to you is heuristic,
from physical perspective.
So if you think about the
sphere embedded in the space--
so this is [INAUDIBLE].
So if you think from, say,
imagine your time going up.
OK?
Imagine your time going up.
So this [INAUDIBLE] you
nucleate an infinitesimal string
at the tip of the sphere, and
then this stream propagates.
So then each time,
you have a string.
And then, at some future time,
then go back to the vacuum.
OK?
And so you just have a
string come in and come out--
a string come out from the
vacuum, and then go back.
And the sphere just described
this kind of virtual process.
So you look at string,
and then disappear.
OK?
Say nucleate string--
string nucleation,
and it then disappears.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why did we only
talk about close strings?
PROFESSOR: Because it's
enough for my purpose now.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
I'm not trying to give
you the full string
theory at the moment.
I'm just trying to give you
the bit of string theory
that's enough to
make that point.
Say large N expansion
is like string theory.
Yeah.
Yeah, because otherwise,
take the whole semester
to reach the point.
So now, let's look at
this torus diagram.
Because if you want the
sum of all surfaces,
then you have to sum over
different topologies,
then you have to
sum over the torus.
Then let's look at what
torus diagram means.
So let me show the torus in
the slightly different way.
OK?
So the torus, again, if you try
to view the time going up, then
from here, again, you do
create the single string.
But now, at this time, then
you actually have two strings.
And then, here, you have
one string back again.
OK?
And then the torus
actually describes
such a virtual process, is
that you nucleate a string
from the vacuum.
And then this string
splits into two strings.
And then these two
strings come back
to join, again,
into a single string
and then go to the vacuum.
OK?
So this is the
nucleation out of vacuum.
And then here, it splits.
So here, a single string
splits into two string.
And then here, they
join together, join back
into a single string.
And then here, disappear
into the vacuum.
OK?
So we find, by including the
torus diagram you automatically
include this kind
of interaction,
that the string can
split into two strings,
and two strings can
join into single string.
And essentially, you
don't have choice.
This is just determined
by the topology.
OK?
You don't have choice.
Just once you write
down this path integral,
then this is fully determined.
OK?
It's fully determined.
And similarly, if you look
at the [INAUDIBLE] process--
so you look at the string split,
join, splits and join again.
So the [INAUDIBLE]
string again can
see that it has such
in the acting process.
So now the key-- so now if
we compare the gs dependence
of these diagrams.
So this one-- so each diagram,
compared to the earlier one,
you increase by gs
to the power squared.
But whenever you
include a genus,
essentially [INAUDIBLE]
include such a splitting
under the joining.
So that means you can actually
associate with each process
to be a factor of g string.
OK?
So for the sphere, you
have-- say from here.
Say if you normalize a
sphere to be gs minus 2,
then now if you
include-- so essentially,
this weight which
we added here is
to wait for such a splitting
and the joining process.
So each splitting and
joining essentially
give you a weight of g string.
OK?
Weight g string.
So in some sense, we concluded
that-- so the basic string
interaction vertex is just a
single string can join into two
string, or two string--
or single string
can split into two
string, or two string
can join into a single string.
And the weight for each
process is given by g string.
OK?
So that's effectively what
this mathematical trick does.
So effectively what this
mathematical trick does
is to assign a weight for
each such splitting process.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if
you start the-- so
you drew it like this
for the two thing.
But if you start the nucleation
from the side rather than
the bottom, then wouldn't
it split into three
and then back into one?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Yeah, it's-- because
of the topology,
you can split in
an arbitrary way.
And this just tells you,
using this basic vertex, then
for fixed parameterization--
yeah, this vertex already
enough.
And you can-- indeed,
it's a very good question.
You can try to slice the
diagram in arbitrary way.
Then that may give you some
arbitrary other things.
Then that's fine.
And then you can assign weight
for some other vertices.
But they will be
all consistent with
these fundamental vertices.
So essentially this
gs, which I called
to be-- exponential
lambda, it's essentially
the coupling for the string.
OK?
It essentially
determines the strength
of the string interactions.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Our choice of
weight is not unique, right?
[INAUDIBLE] something
ugly like [INAUDIBLE] chi
squared and then including that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that's a good point.
Indeed.
Yeah.
So here is the simplest choice.
And it's a choice
which you can-- yeah.
So this is the simplest
choice you can put,
and then this is a
choice which will also
arise if you property
quantize string theory.
And indeed, you can write
down some other string theory
with a different power.
It might be possible.
Yeah.
I mean just as a mathematical--
say at the mathematical level,
it doesn't prevent you to add
some arbitrary function of chi.
And this is just the
simplest way to do it.
And this is the way which
arises out of string theory.
Yeah.
So this process
is not arbitrary.
It's something which you can
derive from string theory.
Just here, we will not go
through the whole thing.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Do we have an extra
minus sign in the exponent?
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
Because chi goes-- it's more
negative as h increases?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So the exponent
becomes larger and larger?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
Because I can take
g to be small.
Yeah.
Yeah, the only thing
is I want to be
consistent with this power.
So now, here is the key.
So now let's look at
the external strings.
So here, at the
beginning, I was looking
at the-- I was looking
at the vacuum process.
There was nothing.
Just everything come
out of the vacuum.
But you also consider,
say, some process.
Say you started
with two strings.
Then you scatter them together,
you get two string back.
So you can also consider
such kind of strings.
So you started with actually
two initial strings.
And then through some
complicated interaction,
then you have two strings back.
OK?
So for example, this would
be such kind of process.
Anything can happen between.
I have two initial
strings, but I have
two final strings come out.
OK?
So this would be some
kind of surfaces.
So this would--
because when do you
have your sum of all
possible surfaces which
four external string-- say,
two coming from minus infinity,
and two come from
t [INAUDIBLE], two
come out at t plus infinity.
OK?
And again, you need to sum
of all possible topology
in between.
Say you sum over
sphere in between.
Yeah, let me just save
time, draw it quickly.
So you can sum over
all spheres in between.
Some spheres.
Or you sum over
torus, et cetera.
OK?
But now, if you do this weight,
according to this rule-- OK?
Now if you do the weight
the according to this rule,
something changed.
Because again, we want you
sum of all possible surfaces
with the same rule as
you do for the vacuum.
But now, there's something
important that changes.
So these are the [INAUDIBLE]
with the boundaries.
So you want to start with
two initial strings and two
final strings.
So each initial string
could use a boundary.
So now you have four
different boundaries.
So you have four boundaries.
And so when you
introduce boundaries
into two-dimensional surfaces,
then the Euler number changes.
So sum of you already may
know this from high school.
2 minus h, and the minus n, and
n is the number of boundaries.
OK?
Number of boundaries.
And which is the same as the
number of external strings.
Number of external strings.
OK?
So now, if you use
this rule-- so now
for the n-string scattering--
for n-string scattering--
so let me call this n, An.
Then you will, again,
sum over all genuses.
So now this weight
will translate into gs,
become n minus 2 plus 2h.
OK?
So now, because of this n, so
I have additional power of gs
to the power n.
Say I can write as Fn h.
OK?
So if you look at the sum,
so this is gs to the power
n minus 2 come from the sphere.
The sphere, surface,
[INAUDIBLE] surfaces,
which can be considered
as a tree level
from the string point of
view, because the string
just come out and then nucleate.
And then the next order
is gs to the-- gs n.
Then this is the torus topology.
So this may be considered as
some kind of one-loop process,
and gs n plus 2.
So this is genus 2, et cetera.
OK?
So now, let's compare with this.
So this also included
in the vacuum.
For the vacuum, it just says
n equal to 0-- [INAUDIBLE]
n equal to 0.
So now, we see exactly parallel
with what we see in the large N
gauge series.
In both cases, you have
summing over topology.
And in both cases,
we'll have summing--
you have this expansion.
So identical
mathematical structure
with large N expansion.
In particular, g string now
corresponds into just 1 over N.
And these external strings--
say if you have some-- just
goes 1 into the glueballs,
what we call the glueballs.
So these kind of
single trace operators.
And the sum of string-- over
string worksheet of, say,
topology of genus h is
mapped to, say, sum over
Feynman diagrams of genus h.
Yeah.
So you see an exactly parallel
mathematical structure
between the two.
So the question, is
this an accident?
Or this is something deep?
OK?
I think I'm running out of time.
Yeah.
OK.
Maybe I will stop here.
Oh, you don't want to stop?
AUDIENCE: There's only
1 and 1/2 pages left.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah.
Let me just say a few words.
Let me say a few words.
If you look at these two
sums-- this sum and this sum.
Oh, yeah, let me call this fn.
So that's a distinction.
Let me call this f.
So that's f.
So if you look at these two
sums-- so the question is,
can you really physically
identify these two?
OK?
Let me just say a couple words.
Say fn h, which will appear
in the correlation functions,
essentially just sum over
Feynman diagrams of genus h.
And this is just the
Feynman diagrams--
the expansion for
the Feynman diagrams.
And this one, this
fh-- fn h-- So this
is sum over-- this
is path integral,
say minus SNG of
genus h surfaces.
So now remember one
thing we said before.
We said each Feynman
diagram can be considered
as a partition of a 2D surface.
OK?
So now, if you sum over all
possible Feynman diagrams--
so you can also think
of it geometrically
as sum of all possible
triangulations of a surface.
So this kind of partition
essentially just
a triangulation of the surfaces
divided into different parts,
and with some amplitude--
with some weight.
So sum of all possible
triangulations
over the surface, of
course this is precisely
just a discrete form of
summing over all surfaces.
So this just a discrete sum
of summing over all surfaces.
And so this really identified
these two are essentially
the same object.
So when you're
summing over diagrams,
you're actually summing
[INAUDIBLE] actually summing
over all possible embeddings
of some surfaces in spacetime.
And the precise nature of
the surface, of course,
depends on the diagram itself.
So this really tells you
that the larger N expansion
is really just a string theory.
OK?
It's really just
a string theory.
But from here, you cannot
immediately tell what kind
of string theory is this.
Because from famine
Feynman diagram itself--
so this Nambu-Gotu action,
which I wrote earlier,
goes 1 into your map,
from some surface--
embedding of some surface
in some spacetime.
And that spacetime can be some
arbitrary spacetime, et cetera.
For a different
spacetime, of course,
you get a different action.
So the question is, what
does this correspond to?
Say I give you a
field series, and you
have those Feynman diagrams.
And what Feynman-- and
for each Feynman diagram,
you can write down
expression for them.
Just whether this really
corresponding to, say,
some geometric actions.
The Feynman diagrams
[INAUDIBLE] really
cause some geometric
action describing
the motion of some
surface in some spacetime.
Yeah.
So let me just stop here.
[APPLAUSE]